foreign
ER in D-Town in Dallas Texas what's up
Jennifer
hi Dr John how are you I'm good how are
you
pretty good I'm
actually getting
because I'm talking to you
monkey
no definitely not I can't handle it good
for you good for you
it's a healthy brain you got there all
right so what's up
well my question for you is
might be a less controlling significant
other so I just had a
seventh month relationship end because I
kind of suffocated the guy
and I'd
like to
work on that part of myself so I kind of
want to know where that comes from and
yeah I kind of hate that part of myself
so I'd like to figure out how I can work
on it and understand it well I don't
want you to hate any part of yourself
can we start there
sure okay
um something about a relationship
set your body on guard
and really makes your body worried about
somebody abandoning you or somebody
hurting you
and is trying to solve that by really
tightening up your grip
and so I just want to honor the fact
that your body's trying to take care of
you in the best way it knows how and
ah you've learned that it
chokes people unconscious and so we're
just going to learn a different
different set of tools
but I don't want you to start from a
place of hate is that cool
cool or as my friend Ian simkin says
um
whatever you think your hate is doing
Love Can Do Better
okay so let's start from that place is
that fair
okay what makes you think you smothered
this guy
um well he told me
okay so this is a spoiler alert and if
I'm the first person first person ever
tell you this I am so sorry
but sometimes guys make up bull crap to
get out of relationships
um yeah a lot of people who love me in
my life have told me that that's bull
crap all right
um I regardless I do still have those
kind of controlling feelings and I would
still like to deal with them in a more
healthy way okay teach me about your
controlling feelings tell me about them
um
well mainly the idea of him just going
off and having fun maybe a guy's weekend
or anything without me
I just kind of have a fear of missing
out
like
I
I don't like I want to be a part of that
um
let me think
um let's take him off the table when
have you done this before
give me an example
this relationship that just ended he was
gonna go away on a ski trip with his dad
for like two weeks and
um I just couldn't mentally wrap my
brain around the idea that he didn't
want to spend those two weeks with me
like why can't I come why don't you want
to have that fun with me because
the person I'm dating kind of becomes my
whole world and I I would not ever go on
a trip without him because he's my
favorite thing and I would rather stay
in town to spend time with him or take
him with me on a trip and I just can't
even fathom
wanting a two-week break from a person
and the way you're framing this is so
instructive
so relationships for you are not for
connectivity relationship for you is a
drug
who left you
um
when I was somebody somebody hurt you
bad who did it
well how much time do you have doctor no
I was not hurt that bad um as a teenager
um my mom left and
um she kind of just didn't reach out for
months I I would call and she would
answer I think she's pretty like ashamed
of just breaking up our family Jennifer
Jennifer Jennifer
that's really bad
don't ever minimize that again
okay
how old were you
like 17.
and my guess is when somebody does that
they've usually left that relationship
years before they actually walk out the
door
is that fair
yeah did your mom struggle with
addiction
um no
why'd you leave
um she was just really unhappy with
their marriage I think she was more
trying to prove a point she wanted my
dad to fight for her to care to show
show her
interests she wanted I think she wanted
his attention and he just
took the other Road and said you're
being ridiculous get back over here and
they 100 just let it fall apart
did you have to fight for attention as a
kid to get your mom to notice you
um
yeah yeah I think so yeah what about Dad
um dad's love was I guess what you would
call merit-based conditional as long as
yeah as long as I was doing something
accomplishing something and I will say
after my mom left my dad he had to get a
second job and then he started dating
and he disappeared too and then the same
thing with my older siblings
um she kind of leaned on all her friends
and I was just kind of Forgotten
I mean you just laid it out
yeah but how do I fix this
um so let's let's run through that map
real quick so you grow up and you have a
picture
that love is Mom starts a fire and Dad's
job is to put it out that's how that's
how she receives love
mm-hmm
she causes a scene and he has to come
rescue her and if he doesn't rescue her
he doesn't love her
I can imagine a scenario where Dad gets
really tired of that over the years
right and he begins to create an ALT
universe that you probably will never
fully understand because they're
probably not going to ever tell you the
full picture maybe they will but who
knows
so you have this picture
of
you bet if you if you don't come get me
you don't love me
and love for you was a tool
right
it was the key to Dad it was the key to
Mom
and then all of a sudden oh
they vanished
and like a kid who was
thrown off the back of a boat and a
stick comes by that kid is going to
cling to that stick as tight as they can
yeah until it snaps
okay so every time you enter into a
romantic relationship Jennifer it's not
it's not about connectivity it's not
about peace it's about oxygen
yeah 100 yeah
the only way I know through this there's
two two paths to take uh actually
there's one path with two action steps
on it action step number one is you have
to commit to loving you enough to go see
a counselor to work through a lifetime
of trauma
yeah
um I actually
am on my third week with somebody from
better health so
yeah I'm so excited about it I'm so
excited about it good I'm I'm really
proud of you because that's hard because
saying something out loud got you hit
when you were a kid you don't have to
answer that
and
you're going to have to practice
feeling overwhelmed
and not making relationships some zero
because when you enter into a
relationship it becomes you versus
everybody else in the in the person you
love's life
you versus their dad you versus their
mom you versus their old friends you
versus everybody their boss
that's just not fair
to you or to them right and so you're
gonna have to practice when your
boyfriend that you care about you've
been with seven months says hey I'm
gonna go spend a week with my dad
you're gonna have to practice feeling
that wash over your body
whoo
and then going and doing the next right
thing which is saying that is so amazing
that you and your dad still want to
spend time together I'm super jealous of
that that's awesome
and then you go home and you feel left
out you feel alone I want you to sit in
that call somebody write that stuff down
because you know that's not true
your feelings aren't telling you the
truth because what your feelings are
telling you is that guy's leaving you
he's picking Dad over you he's always
going to leave and your body screams
don't let him go
that's a lie it's not true
he's just gonna hang out this old man
which by the way if he has the kind of
relationship he wants to go spend two
weeks with his dad he'll make a great
husband
right
right you're gonna have to choose to
enter into the fire for a season until
your body recognizes oh oh
they left
mom left
dad bailed
but that doesn't mean he will
it's gonna be hard now I just threw a
lot at you and I can feel you not
breathing very much tell me what you're
feeling
um
I mean I figured that I'm gonna have to
just muscle through that feeling no no
no no no
no no Jennifer not mustard
opposite
oh you're not swimming Upstream you are
a leaf going Downstream
okay okay when you feel it you're
muscling through it that is that grip
in fact I want you to practice this
consciously when you feel that you're
dating somebody new and they're like hey
I gotta I just got a call I gotta work
late tonight and instantly your body's
like you're choosing work over me
I want you to look down and consciously
open your hands up
uh open them up
we are not muscling through anything the
opposite we are letting go
okay
you don't like that do you
no um I like it it's okay if you hate it
Jennifer it's okay if you hate no I
don't I don't hate it I'm just grateful
for a new thing to try because I mean
this feeling makes me so miserable so I
I don't hate it I'm I'm excited to try
will you write Jennifer a letter
17 year old Jennifer
and I want you to start it off
with this line
seventeen-year-old Jennifer
I love you
and mom left because something was going
on with her not with you
then I want you to tell Jennifer how
beautiful she was
and how sorry you are that Dad
weaponized love
and that Mom weaponized love
and commit to her as older Jennifer
that you are going to redefine love for
your body
so that relationships are not something
that you are not a drug the
relationship's not dope relationships
not oxygen relationship is peace
okay
you don't like that at all
um
no I I don't dislike it
I mean I'll try why are you crying
um
I don't know just
I don't know it's just a lot of emotions
there with talking about it I guess yeah
I'm gonna tell you something crazy
there's nothing wrong with you
thank you I'm not saying that like in
some like Stitch it on a pillow kind of
way you're not broken you're not
dysfunctional
your body's just trying to keep you safe
and the two people the two freaking
people
who are never supposed to leave
they bailed on you
yeah the two people who are supposed to
look at their little bitty girl and say
you can burn down
the tallest building in the world and
you're still my little girl
they didn't do that they said hey if you
uh run real fast
ah
I'll buy you pancakes
if you uh get such and such a grade I'll
wink at you
they weaponize the whole thing man
it's gonna take some time to practice a
new basketball shot and your basketball
shot is
not feeling like everybody's decisions
are anti-jennifer because they're not
when you love somebody and you care
about them or you're dating them and you
like them a lot
and
we're gonna practice wanting the best
for them we're gonna practice them
having great relationships and them
having laughter in them having Joy we're
going to practice those things
because that makes them better able to
love me
to love you
to meet your needs
stay stay stay in counseling okay and at
some point you may need to transition
from better help to an in-person
therapist which is great
you've got a long history two important
things Jennifer never again say it's not
that bad what you experienced as hell
I'm sorry
second thing is you're worth being well
and you're worth the fight
my promise to you is there's peace on
the other side of this
don't stop searching for peace